now that the United States has flattened
the curve President Trump is flattening
the narrative at a White House briefing
that not only brutalized the press but
also prepared the way for a reopening of
our country we will examine the grand
strategy behind owning the libs then a
new study out of Israel suggests the
global economic shutdown was completely
pointless Bernie Sanders endorses Joe
Biden and Joe's lead in the polls
evaporates all that and more I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Nolt
show
[Music]
we've been talking about flattening the
curve that's what we all have to do
flatten that curve spread out the number
of infections that's the goal of the
last three four weeks that's done we've
done that we did a good job
mission accomplished now a much more
pressing matter is flattening the
narrative that the media have been
building the whole time and President
Trump is doing a great job at that one
thing I want to point out about
yesterday's White House press conference
which President Trump has been doing
every single day they've almost all been
extraordinarily entertaining just a
really excellent TV but one thing I want
to point out about yesterday's which was
the most entertaining of all of them is
that the entertainment value was not
just there to make us laugh I think that
President Trump structured this press
conference to achieve a grand strategy
for his reelection campaign in 2020
and it also happened to be absolutely
freaking hilarious so President Trump
gives the usual introduction then he
answers some questions and rather before
he gets to the questions he tees up a
video
he's got the media all in the room he
says you know I want to tee up this
little video just to give you an
overview of the past few weeks and he
tees up the video the video is of the
media getting the coronavirus totally
wrong in February Nancy Pelosi said we
should come to China tab this is late
February come to Chinatown we think it's
very safe come here let's say I'll have
the big parade china town parade
probably referring to San Francisco and
that's it but I took this action early
and so the story in the New York Times
it's a total fake it's a fake newspaper
and they write fake stories and someday
hopefully in five years when I'm not
here those papers are all going out of
business because nobody's going to want
to read them but now they like them
because they write about me now with
that I have a couple of interesting we
have a few clips that we're just going
to put up we could turn the lights a
little bit lower I think you'll find
them interesting
okay that's the setting the stage right
he's saying I think you're gonna like
this you're gonna enjoy it so you
already know given the way he's
introducing this video that this is
gonna be pretty savage right he's making
fun of Nancy Pelosi for telling people
in the early days of the pandemic to
come to Chinatown he's going straight
after the New York Times Trump has
changed his tone day by day in the press
briefing some days very staid very
presidential very bipartisan say nice
thing about Democrats saying nice things
even about the media that wasn't
yesterday yesterday was a major tonal
shift he comes out he goes the New York
Times is a fake piece of trash newspaper
Nancy Pelosi is completely wrong she's a
joke she imperiled lives and hey check
out my video so he tees it up here's the
video itself concern about the corona
virus because they're hearing a lot of
news about it right now
but the reality is comparing it to the
flu for example it's not even close to
being at that stage it goes on and on on
the media but I think you get the gist
look at how he's flipping this because
what the media are accusing Trump of
doing is not taking the coronavirus
seriously of comparing it to the flu for
instance which by the way might be a
fair comparison we'll get to that a
little bit later in the show but
regardless of whether or not it is a
fair comparison that's not what Trump
cares about here what Trump cares about
here is showing that the media were very
recently doing the exact same thing that
they are accusing him of doing this is
what he manages to do all the time he
did this all throughout 2016 it's not
even that he would defend himself
against the attacks from his opponents
in the Republican primary or in the
media all he didn't have to do that all
he would have to do is show that his
opponents and his critics are no better
than he is
so you remember this very clearly with
Jeb Bush Jeb Bush accuses Donald Trump
of being immature in 2016 of being
childish of not being composed of not
being an adult and then Donald Trump on
the debate stage gets he triggers Jeb
Bush Jeb Bush starts getting all angry
he gets really fired up
and he goes how was that Donald was that
high-energy enough and Donald goes yeah
that was high-energy and he puts his
hand out for a low five and then Jeb
like the kid on the playground who
finally got the attention of the bully
and you know a bully didn't give him a
swirly
Jeb got so excited that he kind of jumps
up a little bit and smacks Trump's hand
totally destroys jeb bush's argument
that jeb is the mature person
jeb is gonna behave like the adult in
the room because he was behaving in just
as giddy and childish away as donald
trump that's what he's doing here to the
media he's done this again and again I
mean do you remember when Hillary
Clinton was saying that if you can test
the results of the 2016 election you're
a threat to democracy
what does Trump get her to do contesse
the results of the 2016 election so
that's what's happening here
the press are just watching themselves
he he says look at this video and it's
just a mirror basically up in the front
of the room to show the press who they
are then the video moves on to its
second stage which is no longer going
after the press with their own words
it's showing how Trump took the virus
seriously
[Music]
well we've asked them to accelerate
whatever they're doing in terms of a
vaccine we will be suspending oil travel
from Europe to the United States for the
next 30 days to unleash the full power
of the federal government in this effort
today I am officially declaring a
national emergency so you see here what
Trump is doing he's saying you're
accusing me of not taking it seriously
look at all the clips of me taking it
seriously now to be fair were there also
clips of President Trump saying that the
media were being alarmist early on yes
again that doesn't matter
the media has this very narrow narrative
that they have been constructing which
totally ignores their own behavior their
own hypocrisy so President Trump is
constructing a parallel narrative so he
hits he hits the media he then hits how
great a job he's doing and then he goes
on to the governor's praising Trump and
the brilliance of this three-part video
strategy is not even in the video we've
all seen these clips before it's that he
knew exactly how it would trigger the
media and it turned out he was right
we'll get to that a second first I have
got to thank all of our sponsors who
were sticking with us because obviously
these are very tough economic times for
every company just about and so we
really want to thank the sponsors who
are allowing us to keep the show on the
air and if you appreciate them like we
appreciate them then maybe go over there
and give our sponsors a look and help
them out especially these days you got
to check out ray Khan because there's
nowhere to go right now pretty much all
you have are the media to entertain you
and the prerequisite for consuming media
right now is a solid pair of earbuds
okay everybody needs a great pair of
wireless earbuds and before you go
dropping hundreds of dollars on a pair
you need to check out the wireless
earbuds from Ray Khan if you're still
using cords first of all get out of the
19th century check out the newest model
from break on the everyday e25 earbuds
they're the best ones yet six hours of
playtime seamless bluetooth pairing more
bass a more compact design that gives
you a nice noise isolating fit they look
a lot better they feel a lot better than
some of those
is shall we say overpriced earbud brands
I'm not going to name names you know
what I'm talking about now is the time
to get the latest and greatest from Ray
Khan get 15% off your order at buy rake
on Comm slash Knowles kena wles
that's buy rake on.com slash Knowles for
15% off rake on wireless earbuds buy
rake on Comm slash Knowles all right he
tees it up shows the media their own
words then he shows the media his own
words in the third part the piece de
resistance is he shows the media the
Democratic governors who are praising
him so the New York Times can't say
anything nice about him CNN can't say
anything nice about him the supposedly
objective journalists but Trump's own
political adversaries are going to be
more fair to him than the allegedly
objective press here's the third part
his team is on it they've been
responsive late at night early in the
morning and they've thus far been doing
everything that they can do and I want
to say thank you and I want to say that
I appreciate it he returns calls he
reaches out he's been proactive we got
that mercy ship down here in Los Angeles
that was directly because he sent it
down here okay this I think is
unprecedented in history of press
briefings first of all the fact that
President Trump holds his own press
briefings every single day is also
unprecedented I mean the guy is
obviously playing to his strengths
because he's so good on camera he's so
good at communicating but to be this
brazen to be this bold is there's
obviously something going on underneath
the strategy it's not merely a troll and
we'll get to what that is in a second
but President Trump gives you this ice
cream sundae right this 3-part ice cream
sundae just in case that wasn't going to
send the media into a tizzy he gives
them a little cherry on top of the
sundae and that little that little
cherry on top is that he quotes one of
their only reporters not just any
reporter perhaps one of the most
partisan reporter
Maggie Haberman Hillary Clinton said
that Maggie Haberman czar favorite
reporter because she would always cover
Hillary in a positive light
Trump adds this little bit of Maggie
Haberman having to admit that Trump is
doing a good job so now you've got an
actual member of the press a far left
one contradicting the press coverage
that we've been seeing for the past two
weeks on President Trump and that was
the straw that broke the camel's back as
there were more cases and it was clear
that it was spreading out of China where
it originated the president took this
move that he was widely criticized for
by Democrats and even some Republicans
at the time which was he halted a number
of flights from China into the u.s. the
idea was to halt the spread of the
disease
keep transmissions to a minimum he was
accused of xenophobia he was accused of
making a racist move at the end of the
day it was probably effective it was
probably effective Maggie Haberman at
the New York Times they could not
believe it
it was so brazen it was so brutal
they've tried their best to flip it on
him but they were so defeated they were
so taken taken aback by this that they
couldn't do it the best move to try to
flip this on Trump came from Jon Karl
over at ABC who Trump has been
humiliating in these press conferences
and Jon Karl took took the one angle he
could see which is he said that it
looked like a campaign ad and he wanted
to find out who made the ad because
maybe Trump was using White House
resources inappropriately for campaign
activities because that was a campaign
ad that he just forced all of the
mainstream media to play for him for
free on their networks and Trump like he
was waiting for it he was waiting for
that little toss up knocks it out of the
park and he says wait a second you think
that me playing your own ridiculous
words is a campaign ad what does that
say about you I've never seen a video
like that played in this
it looks a bit like a campaign ad who
who produced that video well that was
done by a group in the office and it was
done just by we just put some flips
together I could give you I'll bet you I
have over a hundred more clips even
better than them they were just pieced
together over the last two hours that
was just oh we have far better than that
that's nothing compared to some bows was
produced here in the White House yeah
this was done by a Dan and a group of
people and they just put it together in
a period of probably less than two hours
do you feel need to do that because
we're getting fake news and I like to
have it correct it how did John Carl not
notice the flaw in his own question
he's so he goes why did you feel the
need to do that to do what John what did
he do
he just played your own words back to
you why did you feel the need to to show
our reporting as if he is now admitting
their reporting is so bad so unfair so
humiliating for them that merely playing
it back on a television is an attack on
the media quoting the media is now an
attack on the media and I agree it is
because the media have humiliated
themselves and that was the trap that
Trump set and it totally worked it
wasn't just him wasn't just him the
former New York Times editor Howell
Raines fell for exactly the same thing
here's how old Raines talking on MSNBC
about it I think this is one of the most
astonishing acts of disinformation we've
seen from a White House since the
Vietnam era and the five o'clock follies
of Lyndon Johnson's administration the
news today and this is one of those days
as a journalist when you have to put on
your analytical hat and hack your way
through what's really happening what
really happened today is that some smart
serious governors governor Newsom on the
west coast
Governor Cuomo governor a lot on the
East Coast took action to prevent the
president from making a thunderous
blunder that would further endanger the
health of the American people this was
dangerous disinformation what happened
today what matters is not what we saw at
the press
it's not our own words it's this other
stuff that happened about the governor's
so if the the Trump press briefing was
dangerous disinformation and if the
centerpiece of the Trump press briefing
was just playing the reporters own words
back to them it would seem to follow
that the mainstream media reporting is
dangerous disinformation he falls into
it too
not just him okay the question is who
melted down here the the narrative right
now that the meteor trying to spin is
that Trump had a meltdown and the
seriously this was trending on Twitter
they say Trump had a meltdown you just
saw it does he look like he had a
meltdown no he just played a video of
his people speaking and then the press
had a meltdown because the left is
always projecting we'll get to that in
just one second but first I got to thank
our friends over at LifeLock you know
you know there's some people who are
just prepared for everything don't you
some people who if they have a cut you
know they've just got a band-aid right
ready to go there are some people who if
you need a battery they'll have multiple
sizes on hand but if they're worried
about identity theft and only monitoring
their credit they may not be as prepared
as they think breaches seem like they're
happening more these days and with your
breached information such as your name
your social security number and more
flying around the internet during tax
season by the way criminals can commit
identity theft that's why life lock sees
more threats like someone taking out a
payday loan in your name for incidence
alerts you to possible suspicious
activity if you end up having an issue
they have a dedicated identity
restoration specialist just a phone call
away no one can prevent all identity
theft or monitor all transactions at all
businesses but doesn't make sense to be
prepared when you can go to LifeLock
comm slash Knowles canna wles
that's a Lifeloc dot-com / Knowles ko
wles
to save 25% who really melted down
that's the question now the media are
reporting this as a trump meltdown
here's Jim Acosta Jim Acosta inge all
over
story I have to tell you that is the
biggest meltdown I have ever seen from a
President of the United States in my
career I don't think a reasonable person
could watch what we just saw over the
last hour and conclude that the
president is in control he sounds like
he is out of control he sounds like he's
totally out of control because he played
our own words back to us okay you saw
you saw how Trump reacted compare that
to John Karl who looked like he was
gonna cry he looked so crestfallen and
upset and Jim Acosta obviously seems
pretty upset on that clip Trump didn't
just shred the reporters with their own
words he pointedly when they were trying
they were just kept trying to attack him
from different angles he just doesn't
care anymore okay there was there's no
more veneer there's no more pretend that
he's gonna play nicely with them he's
not doing it here is Trump ripping apart
a CBS reporter all I'm saying is this
how do you close down the greatest
economy in the history of the world when
on January 17th
you have no cases and no death when on
January 21st you have one case and no
death one case to think of that now
we're supposed to close down the country
but here's what happened when On January
31st I instituted the band Joe Biden
went crazy he said you don't need the
band you he didn't go crazy like he just
he didn't even know what the hell the
band was but he so he didn't go crazy
but he did say he did call me Xenophon
wait a minute
he called me xenophobic he called me a
racist because he has since apologized
and he said I did the right thing so
when you say why didn't you this every
Democrat thought I made a mistake when I
did it I saved tens of thousands maybe
hundreds of thousands of lives paper
that you bought the argument is that you
bought yourself some time you did
to prepare hospitals you didn't use it
to ramp up testing so you circus were so
disgraceful the way you said it so
disgraceful absolutely who could
disagree with that the media it was just
an all-out brawl okay the media we're
getting their hits in Trump was getting
his hits in CNN ran for crazy Chi runs
in five minutes one said angry Trump
turns briefing into propaganda session
next one Trump refuses to acknowledge
any mistakes
next one Trump uses task force briefing
to try and rewrite history and
coronavirus responds next one Trump
melts down an angry response to reports
he ignored virus warnings what's this
all about
what's this about this is not just about
Trump trying to move on from the
coronavirus news cycle it's not just him
signaling that he wants to move on this
is how Trump moves on from the
coronavirus news cycle and we got
reports yesterday that Trump he wants to
try to start reopening by May first
which he should he should frankly do it
sooner if he can he's he's not gonna win
if he keeps defending himself he's done
an excellent job on the coronavirus
response the media are dishonest tax and
they're gonna attack him for as we just
saw opposite reasons because he didn't
do enough or because he did too much
they're gonna go after him either way
it's gonna be unfair that's not a battle
he can win so he's got to move on now
and the way that he's gonna move on is
not by asking nicely to move on the way
he's gonna move on is by playing what is
essentially a campaign ad during the
White House briefing even though the
campaign ad is just the mainstream
media's own words he's going to force
their hand that's what he did yesterday
and he's forcing them to get back to
20/20 coverage and you know what credit
where credit's due
you don't need to just take my word for
it here the jackals over at Media
Matters finally caught on to how much
this foolish press is helping President
Trump so my friend over there Jason
Campbell who is you know Media Matters
is this left-wing operative group but
unlike other left-wing operative groups
instead of trying to get politicians
fired they try to get media people fired
and there's no version of this on the
right it's only on the left because they
hate that conservatives can communicate
they can't
the arguments that we're making so they
just tried to silence us and so anyway
the one guy who's assigned to me and
some of the other daily wire people
jason campbell who i actually sort of
get a kick out of he recognized the
strategy here right so he tweets out not
that networks should ever have been
broadcasting these Trump rallies closed
dis press briefings but if they're now
gonna run campaign ads for free on their
airtime they clearly have learned
nothing from 2016 that's true
right Trump is always using the media to
get free publicity I think he got was
something like two billion dollars worth
of free press in 2016
Campbell sent out another tweet he was
responding to someone who said they can
keep putting all the sassy Chiron's on
screen they want it doesn't matter what
matters is when the network's stop
airing the briefing and start covering
it and Campbell responded to that over
at Media Matters and he said this is
just dawning on the network's now they
had to air a campaign ad for free to
realize these are propaganda sessions so
I give Campbell and Media Matters credit
for recognizing how Trump is
manipulating the presses own hackery
to work against them there is a little
irony here though because Media Matters
watches my show every single day and
then takes out some of the best clips
from my show and posts them themselves
with little snarky comments and they
think that the little snarky comments
are gonna matter more than the exposure
that Media Matters is giving to my show
and the other shows here at the Daily
wire but that they are doing exactly
what they're criticizing the media of
doing for Trump so anyway I just want to
thank Media Matters for doing that
you're astute in your observation you're
definitely helping us to spread our show
so thank you very much and keep up the
good work it was not just Trump who was
owning the press yesterday and having a
good time doing it okay everyone was
getting in on this it's not just a
single zinger right this was clearly a a
well thought out strategy this is what
you're gonna see moving into the future
even doctor foul Qi got in on the fun
doctor foul she's a pretty buttoned-up
guy but even he went after the press cuz
the press have been trying to sow
division and get doctor foul Qi fired
and get Trump pitted against foul Qi so
foul she was asked
basically please doctor foul Qi please
disagree with president Trump and Trump
wouldn't bow she rather wouldn't do it
he ended up backing the president we had
been talking before any meetings that we
had about the pros and the cons the
effectiveness or not of strong
mitigations so discussions were going on
mostly among the medical people about
what that would mean the first and only
time that dr. Burks and I went in and
formally made a recommendation to the
president to actually have a quote shut
down in the sense of not really shut
down but to really have strong
mitigation we discussed it obviously
they would be concerned by some that in
fact that might have some negative
consequences nonetheless the president
listened to the recommendation and went
to the mitigation the next second time
that I went with dr. Burks into the
president and said 15 days are not
enough we need to go 30 days obviously
there were people who had a problem with
that because of the potential secondary
effects nonetheless at that time the
president went with the health
recommendations and we extended it
another 30 days so foul she's saying
Trump did what we asked him to do Trump
listened to the advice of the medical
professionals I got no problem with
Trump try stop trying to sow discord the
press wouldn't leave it at that though
the press actually asked dr. pouchy if
he was being honest or if Trump had just
bullied him into backing him they asked
him dr. Fauci are you voluntarily saying
all of these things and the disgust with
which dr. fowey regards the media became
so clear because what an offensive
question say yeah but are you telling
the truth yeah but are you lying yeah
but are you being bullied yeah but are
you weak he looks at me goes excuse me
everything I do I do voluntarily
everything I do is voluntarily please
don't even imply that please don't even
imply that what a
Savai'i by the way if the press are
trying to ingratiate themselves to
doctor foul Qi and turned foul she
against Trump not doing a good job of it
this was one of the most glorious press
conferences in American history however
it was not without its flaws there was
one bit in here that Trump got an aspect
of our governmental system factually
incorrect he seemed in the clip to
misunderstand federalism and he said
it's not up to the states on whether or
not they want to reopen actually the
president has total control issues my
mind
because it's not me this is when
somebody's the president of the United
States the authority is total and that's
so it's gotta be total you have a couple
of bands of Democrat governors but they
will agree to it they will agree to
other but the authority of the President
of the United States having to do with
the subject we're talking about his
total now that last bit is important
he's not saying the president has total
power like he's a dictator he's saying
that on this subject the president has
total power which is also not true by
the way the the states do have
considerable authority on how to reopen
federal government has a little bit of
authority there too but sure okay
president Trump is misrepresenting
federalism here everybody everybody and
their mother pounced on Trump for this
you know you heard the the same chorus
that you always hear from the squishy
Republican crowd they said what would
you have said if a Barack Obama had said
this let's be fair here because Donald
Trump said this and you're gonna mostly
give him a pass you'll maybe say he was
wrong but then not harp on it too much
but if Trump had said this you would
have her if Obama rather had said this
you would have parked on it a lot they
think this is some sort of profound
question this profound insight that we
treat radical left
differently than we treat conservatives
they think this exposes some kind of
hypocrisy it's actually quite simple we
would have reacted differently to Barack
Obama because Barack Obama was Barack
Obama and Donald Trump is Donald Trump
what why do we think that ideology
doesn't matter here okay if we've got a
president who has done a very good job
who's got a good track record who we can
rely on at least to a considerable
degree to advance conservative
priorities and steward the government in
a good way
what maniac would not give him a little
bit more grace than the guy who's a
radical leftist who has an apparent
antipathy for the country who says he
wants to fundamentally transform the
country who lies through his teeth when
it comes to matters of Public Policy
like if you can if you like your doctor
you can keep your doctor who regards
half of his countrymen as bitter
clingers who he holds in contempt yeah
of course we're gonna treat Trump a
little bit better than that
that's perfectly natural and it's
perfectly reasonable to do that so did
Trump get the point on federalism a
little bit off yeah sure he did
is it gonna spoil my day no I'm glad
that he knows now that you know he's the
state's have a little bit more authority
but okay whatever move on other than
that it was an excellent press
conference and it achieved the goal of
moving past coronavirus and there are a
lot of reasons I think that we should
probably move past coronavirus in the
near future one of those is given by a
legendary conservative figure Bill
Bennett Bill Bennett was the education
secretary under Ronald Reagan he's been
a long time on the conservative scene
Bill Bennett is now bringing back this
argument that perhaps the corona virus
is not like Ebola so much as it's like
the seasonal flu maybe it's not gonna
kill two million people like we were
told initially maybe it's actually gonna
kill closer to them maybe 60,000 people
is the current estimate now what's funny
about this is this is the argument that
the press was making in the early days
of the pandemic that now they're
criticizing Trump for making in the
early days of the pandemic that now
President Trump is not making but
increasingly looks plausible how do we
make sense of all of that we'll get to
Bill Bennett we'll get to a new study
out of Israel
which is backing up what Bill Bennett is
saying at least about reopening the
economy then we'll get to the big
endorsement Bernie Sanders caves like he
always does because bernie is a loser
we'll get to that we'll get to Biden's
evaporated lead but first oh do I have a
deal for you I love this deal this may
be this is my favorite deal we've ever
run so when you become a daily wire
insider plus or all access member
usually you get one leftist here's
tumblr that's pretty good right that's a
good deal well the reason I like this
deal more is because you don't just get
one tumblr you get two tumblers
I like how straightforward it is
sometimes deals promos they're kind of
complicated you get this and that no
this is very simple you like one one is
good well guess what two is better it's
gonna be great by the way we've got a
surprise for current subscribers coming
too so hold out for that but if you were
not subscribing right now go do it you
get two tumblers daily wire.com slash
subscribe to get started and and you'll
get 10% off with promo code Knowles
that's daily wired.com slash to
subscribe coupon code Knowles
get the rarest of all beverage vessels
times 2 we'll be right back
so bill Bennett Ronald Reagan's
Education Secretary legendary
conservative figure he's going back to
the initial comparison for this
coronavirus which was to the seasonal
flu obviously that comparison would not
have made a lot of sense if we were
talking about two million Americans dead
or 4 million or 6 million Americans dead
or however many they said it was going
to be wouldn't have made sense if we're
talking about 250,000 Americans did but
the current models are now projecting
about 60,000 and so that is within the
range of the seasonal flu here's Bill
Bennett what are we missing about this
virus we see the numbers 22,000 dead how
many cases but you took a step back and
what did you find yeah let's take a step
back the estimates now from the
University of Washington which is the
model everybody has been going on even
though it's been wrong most of the time
by a lot overstating it is now they say
60,000 people will die 61 thousand is
what we lost to the flu in 2017 and 2018
the flu now we all regret the loss of 61
thousand people if that's what it turns
out to be I'm gonna tell you I think
it's going to be less and salute all
those who are working in the frontlines
on this the hospital workers the nurses
the doctors etc and the generosity of
the American people but if you look at
those numbers and see the comparable
we're gonna have fewer fatalities from
this than from the flu for this we
scared the hell out of the American
people we lost 17 million jobs we put a
major dent in the economy we closed down
the schools you heard dr. oz say we
probably had enough to do that shut down
the churches and so on you know this was
not and is not a pandemic but we do have
a panic and pandemonium as a result of
the hype of this and it's really
unfortunate look at the facts I love
that Bill Bennett has the courage to say
this because increasingly this
comparison looks tenable now is this the
flu no it's different it's more
contagious it's new right we don't know
about this that just came out of China
it was covered up by the Chinese
government so it became more virulent
and was able to spread more without us
taking precautions so sure it's a little
bit different but if you look at the
current projected deaths it's very
similar
you're not allowed to make that
comparison anymore because the left is
using the tactic that it always uses
when it can't win the argument is it
just brow beats you it emotionally
manipulates you into not making the
obvious argument so it goes a little bit
something like this say huh 60,000
deaths so that's that's kind of like the
flu I guess the corona virus is a little
bit similar to the flu and yet we
reacted to it so much differently and
then the left will do this they'll say
are you comparing this to the flu or you
are you seriously do you have the gall
that temerity the stupidity to compare
this to the flu and by the time they're
done intimidating you you think oh gosh
maybe I shouldn't have done that I don't
yeah am i wrong yeah no no I'm not I'm
not doing that I'm not but wait a second
yeah why wouldn't I why wouldn't I
because the comparison wouldn't make
sense if you're alarmist numbers turned
out to be correct but they didn't turn
out to be correct actually the numbers
that we suspected were true the whole
time from the very beginning that you
screamed and yelled at us for those
numbers are turning out to be correct so
yes I am making that comparison thank
you very much and it would it would
appear that that comparison
while imperfect because all comparisons
are imperfect that comparison seems to
carry a lot of weight now there's one
argument that the left puts forward to
shut this down they say you can't
compare it to the flu because the only
reason the numbers are so low that
current projected death numbers is
because we shut down the global economy
so it's crazy if we'd listened to you we
would have gotten 2 million people dead
but because we listen to me now the
numbers are going down and ironically
you think this vindicates your stupid
idea but really it vindicates us the
alarmists
who shut down without precedent the
global economy over a virus that we knew
very little about that argument does not
hold up it doesn't hold up for a couple
reasons one because at least in the
recent models which were projecting
100,000 200,000 deaths at least in those
recent models they were already
factoring in social distancing they
already factoring in shutting down the
economy they were factoring on all the
things that we were doing and they're
still wrong but even beyond that there
is evidence coming out more day by day
that the lockdown didn't do anything
most recently we're seeing this from
Israel not just Israel the country
Israel a person the Israeli professor
and public intellectual
Isaac Ben Israel has just looked at some
studies on this
he has concluded that in countries where
they took closure steps shut down steps
like Italy and in countries that have
not taken closure steps like Taiwan or
Singapore the trend of the disease is
almost exactly the same what he found is
there was an increase some cases a
significant increase in the number of
cases until the fourth to sixth week and
then immediately after that there is
moderation for a couple weeks or a few
weeks until the eighth week and then it
declines and disappears what's different
about what this Israeli intellectual
professor Isaac ben-israel is looking at
and the models that we based our policy
on is that Isaac bin Israel is looking
at the real hard data not just the
prediction models and the real hard data
are showing that perhaps the lockdowns
didn't achieve very much at all he says
this is happening both in countries that
have closed down like us and in those
that have not closed down until today
like Sweden every country no matter its
response the decline and rise occur
according to the same timeline it's
clear to us how the epidemic is starting
and what is causing the increase what is
causing the moderation is unclear which
means there is a world I'm not saying
this is certainly the case but there is
evidence that we shut down this global
economy we threw 16 million Americans
out of work for three weeks just in just
in three weeks not for three weeks
they're gonna be out of work a lot
longer than that
and when we get the unemployment numbers
this Thursday they're gonna be a lot
more people unemployed a lot of lives
ruined a lot of people going back to
drug addiction a lot of people who will
commit suicide because
that always happens in economic
downturns will be a lot of negative
consequences from this possibly for
nothing
based on no evidence the mainstream
media and the leftist politicians who
did this are gonna have a lot to answer
for and I think President Trump is
recognizing this now and I think that's
why he is signaling that we've got to
move on past this we've got to get out
and get the economy going as fast as
possible because by the way we're
running out of time
every day this drags on it's going to be
that much harder to restart the economy
and that could cost Trump the election
in November and maybe the media and the
left had that in their mind the whole
damn time
speaking of the election in November we
now have a presumptive Democratic
nominee for president
Joe Biden and Bernie Sanders loser as he
ever was is admitting defeat and for all
his purported radicalism is endorsing
the establishment nominee Joe Biden
today I am asking all Americans I'm
asking every Democrat I'm asking every
independent I'm asking a lot of
Republicans to come together in this
campaign to support your candidacy which
I endorse hold on what was that sound
that just came out of Joe did you hear
that was Anne I'm asking them men to
support your candidacy oh what's that
sound was that supposed to express
surprise what what is he surprised about
surely he's not surprised that bernie is
endorsing his campaign that's the whole
reason they were on that live stream
that's what they've been negotiating for
weeks that couldn't have been the
surprise maybe for Joe Biden the
surprise was that he's running for
president at all it's gonna be an
unpleasant surprise oh I got to do that
still oh no that's terrible I just want
to I doesn't want to sit and watch my
stories on the television
Bernie then finishes his endorsement who
makes certain that we defeat somebody
who I believe and I'm speaking just for
myself now is the most dangerous
president in the modern history of this
country okay but you get it you get it
Bernie is going to endorse him we
this was gonna happen Bernie always
rolls over Bernie doesn't want to be a
leader Bernie doesn't want to be the
nominee Bernie doesn't want to be a
front-runner Bernie I'd want to be the
president that would require doing
something and Bernie has never affected
very much public policy at all Bernie
has never led anything in particular
other than a protest movement that's why
when he was a young man he was always
part of these fringe political parties
he didn't seem to have much interest in
really winning he just wanted to be a
gadfly and been he's been a gadfly his
whole career and now he's endorsing Joe
Biden the only reason I mentioned this
is because of one particular irony which
is that Bernie Sanders has endorsed Joe
Biden for president before Barack Obama
has Bernie Sanders the radical socialist
who ran against Joe Biden has endorsed
him before Joe Biden's old boss who he
served under faithfully as vice
president for two terms Barack Obama
Obama just I don't know he just might
not believe in Joe who would that Bernie
endorsement might not mean very much
because Bernie's own spokesman will not
endorse Joe Biden the idea is that if
Bernie endorses Biden then all the
Bernie bros are gonna come over and the
party's gonna unify and that'll be all
well and good maybe not because if
Bernie can't get his own spokesman to
come over how's he gonna get all those
other crazy Bernie bros his spokesman
Brianna joy gray says with the utmost
respect for Bernie Sanders who's an
incredible human being and genuine
inspiration I don't endorse Joe Biden
I supported Bernie Sanders because he
backed ideas like medicare-for-all
canceling all student debt and a wealth
tax Biden supports none of those ouch
ouch
pretty sad Bernie Sanders likely already
has regrets okay because I think
probably Bernie doesn't want to endorse
somebody doesn't want to be blamed for
losing and what does he really care he's
just gonna go back to the Senate you
could see in the endorsement video Joe
Biden starts running off on tangents
that don't make any sense and you can
look if you look deeply in Bernie's eyes
you see oh gosh what have I done at one
point in this endorsement Joe Biden says
so
imperative that he wins because he needs
to create a path to citizenship for
citizens we're gonna finally achieve
comprehensive immigration reform as well
put millions of citizens on a pathway to
citizenship including so many the front
lines right now you can see Bernie
Sanders just yeah yeah I'm with you I'm
with you Oh
What did he say Oh what well we're in it
now okay and he plasters a smile on his
face very sad situation for the
Democratic Party cuz they don't think
that Joe is gonna win and the polls are
showing that too so right now there's a
Fox News poll out of registered voters
showed that Joe Biden's lead over Trump
is gone Joe Biden just a week ago had an
almost 10-point lead over president
Trump nationally now that's gone okay
now they are tied they both have 42
percent support and another 16% say they
would vote for a third-party candidate
or are undecided what changed in that
time Trump has shown leadership on the
coronavirus it didn't have the effect
that Democrats were hoping right what
Democrats were hoping was that the
coronavirus would destroy the economy
throw people out of work I mean Bill
Maher talked about this openly he said
we need a recession because a recession
will kick Trump out of office and it'd
be better for millions of people will
lose their jobs than for Trump to get
reelected so Democrats were openly
campaigning for this or at the media
were openly campaigning for this they
finally got it but it didn't have the
effect that they wanted because
President Trump took control of the
narrative if he had just stayed in the
Oval Office closed off from everybody
and the media were running rampant then
it might have had that effect but he's
not Trump is holding his own press
conferences now he's not just holding
the press conferences answering
questions of Ekron enviros he's
dictating the news of the day every
single day he's showing leadership I
think the leadership thing helped on
those polls he also is showing that he's
ready to turn this around okay and a
down economy four or five months before
the election is not a huge deal if he
can get that economy going again in time
for November and I think that
what he's signaling I think Joe Biden
knows that I think nobody wants to Biden
to lead in a crisis and they're seeing
that moment slip from Joe just like so
many things are slipping from Joe these
days that is one way to pummel the
narrative now what what we all have to
make sure happens is now that we're
pummeling that mainstream media that
leftist narrative now that it's into
oblivion we've got to move forward
that's what President Trump's got to see
is making some signals that he's going
to do that but a lot is going to matter
in the next two weeks we'll see if they
can turn it around we don't have any
more time today but we will get back
into it tomorrow in the meantime I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
madoski
editor and associate producer danny
D'Amico audio mixer robin Fenderson hair
and makeup nikka geneva production
assistant ryan love the michael knowles
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]